when you first started dropping [ __ ] i  remember me and dj head we'd be  listening to your guys's [ __ ] on  soundcloud  and we'd be like jesus christ  can we they need to get someone to mix  and master this [ __ ] yeah  i used to i i used to engineer this [ __ ]  i ain't no [ __ ] engineer  so i used to just hit record we used to  use garageband for the i think we did  mustang on garageband on garageband yeah  we did mustang that's a platinum song  right yeah hell yeah we did musty on  garageband and then we did it it sounded  like it out the apartment  out the apartment that's right remember  we saw hey these guys just got up some  of the mixer bathrooms and [ __ ] this  [ __ ] would be way way it sounded cool to  me because i know the difference but now  you know the difference because all your  records sound crispy as [ __ ] now yeah